Rock Meyer himself right here on the
Rich Eisen show season 3 premiered on
IFC last night and airs every Wednesday
attendees good time good to see you sir
nice to see you Richard I appreciate you
choosing to promote Brock Meyer here
today on the opener the home opener of
the New York Mets season yeah it's a big
day for me are you going to Citi Field
as soon as you're done here that would
have been a great idea I just kind of
said I'll be at richest so I guess I
can't go but I should have just I should
have just gone although it's sold its
way sold out well you can you can figure
this thing I admire myself right on
[Laughter]
right now right now it's one nothing
bottom four who are they playing to it
the plane the Nationals about one nut
there are Nationals that one got
syndergaard versus Mel stottlemyre good
guess yes what do you think your match
so far 111 in won last year to start
need i say more and then 66 wins after
that yeah we'll see okay what I think I
their bullpen is annoyingly shaky right
now okay but I was just telling telling
Joe and others earlier that it's good
because it gives me it keeps mess in
their comfort zone something to really
be upset and worried about and
complained about makes us happiest and I
don't know I see I agree with not
signing Machado or Harper IRA at least I
understand it but why not get another
arm or two that's been driving me crazy
well I mean they got degrom with his 14
strikeouts yesterday I'm at home run and
obviously syndergaard and if Matz and
wheeler can put it together you get the
Mets in a short series you don't want to
face that oh for sure but they're the
most injured team in baseball they need
another another couple arms they just do
I mean if they're doing well they'll
probably get one or two before the
deadline I mean so why I'm there like
literally eight hundred million dollars
below what's it is it 208 what's
a--what's the line for a major league
team salary I don't know well I mean the
way below it we all know that the Mets
might we just will never know how
cash-strapped the Mets have been left by
the whole Madoff thing now we'll just
never know that they paying often SNY
lend them
I have no idea what what buckets they're
using today other buckets all I know is
that Bobby bunny is still being paid yes
and Brett Saberhagen is Saberhagen still
being paid yeah oh yeah and I bet you
they're like what is what would Bobby
bow be on the current Mets roster in
terms of being paid he's probably in the
top 12 his annual salaries probably my
thought it was just like a million bucks
yeah I know but I mean there's probably
a ton of Mets making the league minimum
right now probably Reagan's getting a
250-thousand through 2029 1.19 million
for Bobby Bonilla one point yeah I know
the Mets are 10th in payroll this year
yeah one thing pair all right now 15 but
still we're in New York I know I said he
never sleeps here well the SNY contract
just worth so much money
mm-hmm anyway anyway they need another
couple armar but it's a nice start your
most buoyed in confidence with Mets jets
or Knicks at this moment yeah yeah well
it's definitely not the Knicks we can
just rely on him right we just gave the
dream scenario ping-pong balls bring his
eye on Durant comes because it's a it's
a it's a no-brainer Kyrie comes home and
James Dolan's karma gives him you know
what he wants despite his karma being
the worst karma in the world I don't
want to put you in a position because I
know you like going to games except I
don't I don't want any and you don't
want to get the gate eat exactly enjoy
watching them on TV exactly even
you want to bring your son to these
games even if mr. Dolan and the rest mr.
zall are fortunate enough even if that
happened like Durant Kyrie and Zion it
would be tremendously exciting and we
would but that would not that would not
that's not a championship well I mean
you got Knox right yes well it's not
like the cupboards totally bare Kyrie
makes me nervous now there's a crazy
person yeah but even apart from the
whole the world is flat thing I don't
understand what's happening with in
Boston yeah and he I cannot fit into a
Brad Stevens world
him saying that he loves it there and
then he doesn't give an s as to whether
he stays there or not and it does he's
LeBron wants to go back with LeBron he
misses LeBron he that you left that
snare that could possibly happen right
Carrie goes there
Wow could you imagine that would be man
that would set LA that would be on fire
it would be the flags would come out the
Caerphilly like your car flags they're
all over the place of those Lakers yeah
I don't see that I think Congress days
putting they get Anthony Davis that's
what I think the Lakers will end up in a
game no I think Ari stays put in Boston
and Anthony Davis goes to balls to boss
that they have the most parts that that
the pelicans could use and they send
them to the net other conference they
only see them once a year twice in their
building that's right so that's it I
think ember here then
Kyrie personally okay your lights
Campbell Walker I do okay it's not local
kids okay so Kemba durant right Zion yes
that's a done Knox don't forget don't
forget Phil Jackson's last gift Frank no
lukina yeah well another good idea pass
don't forget a Mitchell for him
right yeah yeah as LeBron pointed out is
what are you so the Jets don't have you
brimming with confidence I'm well let me
on bail evidence come on lovely I have
guarded optimism is the best you're
gonna get from me especially after last
year's Mets 11 in one the Mets are
geniuses at finding new ways to shock
and disappoint their fanbase by the way
that's not a very good annual video
title Shaw shock and disappointment yeah
yeah disappointment I'm pretty sure
that's what the press video was though
shock and disappointment in 2019 shock
and disappointment
yes exist levy on and and and Crowder
and yeah is it Mosley they got CJ Mosley
they spent it
they spent a king's ransom to bring him
right he'll be right in the middle of
the defense that no sugar and we need it
huiyeol line help the edge rush is
coming in the draft sir yeah there are
so many of them who Josh Allen you they
he he'd be a great one
Quintin Williams would be a great one I
love that Oliver from Houston he's the
one who's the closest to Aaron Donald in
terms of body type and flexibility they
need a line help as I know that but
third overall I saw these kids to
combine my them step myself they are
freaks of pass rushing nature right big
time will get that third overall get it
all settled yes madam case Reverend Jim
Mike from taxi because his eyes are
crazy what's that the toxin was the
greatest thing about the taco mean was
was fantastic but right jet fans right
long sort of like all right Adam Gator
all like all right press conference just
you don't even want much from the press
conference just you know speak
intelligently and don't have crazy yeah
just right don't like maybe don't have a
heart attack we saw him at the combine
he did not have them he was totally
normal I suppose that was all about
don't have an answer for you at all but
now that you put the Jim Ignatowski for
taxi into my head it's gonna be tough to
shake it out of there no one you know
New York
no one's gonna let that go unless he has
instant success
no one's gonna ever let him well again
it because everybody wants to win now
everybody knows the Patriots are in the
division everybody remembers Belichick
was the head coach of the New York Jets
for like three days second floor he went
up up the turnpike and got Tom Brady and
you're hoping that at some point they're
gonna catch the same lightning in the
bottle hoping that Donald's that guy you
hire a coach who has an offensive
mindset that Peyton Manning swears by
and he shows up to the press conference
like that like that like Jim Reverend
Jim Ignatowski so that is why I think
it'll be difficult for New York fans to
let go unless
comes out of the gate with love Bell and
I'll think I'll Hank that's the idea
we'll see I you know I just want what do
you think is a realistic expectation for
our New York Jets next year I think the
realistic expectation is that Le'Veon
Bell has that chip on his shoulder and
has that season that you're hoping for
and that Darnell takes the steps forward
that we saw when he came back his foot
injuries ankle injury yeah we've made
some really nice just when it was all
over and we all knew that the coach was
a dead man coaching and they still tried
to win some football games just enough
to screw with their opportunity to be
first over all right Nick Bosa or trade
out because everybody wants calamari but
I'm don't want to go down to jets
wormhole right there may but you did see
darn old looking that good if they can
solidify the offensive line I think the
defense with this crazy man coordinating
it Greg well yeah okay yeah that should
be fun he is he is uh he is a be normal
when it comes to defense happy someone
yes when it comes to defensive
coordinators yeah I think that there's a
possibility to be a wild card team
because I still think it's gonna be New
England you know in the division the
wing yes but can you believe he's
starting for the Miami Dolphins this
year in Ryan Fitzpatrick
oh that that is he now he now leads the
league in most opportunities to start at
quarterback in the history of the
National is that true I don't know god
he's got to I guess he probably does the
Patriots are the only team of the
division he has not started for that's
true it was Jets dolphins well yeah he
plus some others I know it's when total
at seven for attending in in where
there's no signpost or memory to go
green okay seven what do you that is
that we're Vegas that's them yes yes
well yeah I mean that's two more than
last year right did they win five last
year no yeah
it's three more than last year I think
you don't usually win just five games
and go third overall but I'm just
throwing that out at the top twelve I
pass out it's realistic but so that's
not a wild-card team mmm no I don't know
we will see you have we have no idea a
foreign 12 four and twelve Lauren twelve
all right let's talk Brock Meyer uh Hank
Azaria here on the Rich Eisen show 3rd
season of it yes
brach Meyer is a silver man these are
off this season yes
giving up the drink giving up the
substances summer free yes as the kids
like to say so are we seeing him as an
evolving man is he if I suppose so
I mean I guess at least she's not wasted
out of his gourd if you call that
evolving rich as in good on okay and you
do I think you did I do call it a volley
yeah I do because obviously I remember
Jim when he was down on his times yes
when a few people didn't abandon them I
don't know what I'm more proud of of my
role in Brock Maier history being part
of the Funny or Die video that started
it all yes being there for Jim after
that video and having him on the podcast
version of this show yes to do some of
the plays of the month you skip no steps
for the jig's algebras right human
mediocrity is you've never missed a shot
to take a low-hanging fruit shot at at
Tim Tebow never never mr. Jim Brock my
loves hates Tim Tebow he is what does he
say about Tim he o how can you
he loves Tim Tebow because how can you
be that just that horrible at two
separate sports is there anything the
man can't not do he is the bizarro Bo
Jackson so if there's that or last year
yes when a Jim came on the show and
broadside bashed as he always does Brent
Musburger oh yeah that and then had on
Gatsby then it had brunt Musburger
called into the show he did to respond
to Brock Meyer which was a punk-ass be
moved with Costas mediating it in
between was I think to me I think that's
the Protestant we've ever had I know the
Jim's been on many other shows sure but
Musburger yeah chiming he like he
charmed it on Twitter first and it was
all sorts of great is really he was just
looking at an old man anger fit wasn't
he yes if you stepped on as long get off
my lawn
Oh fantastic oh my god that was great so
the voice the Brock Meyer
boy sure as you know is something that
is addictive and you know I've been
doing this for years with Suze and when
we go out together we I see food and I
just say for some reason in Brock Myers
voice I don't know why back sure it is
what we're about to do yes rich called
me today and said I finally did it
I created a food lineup like what who is
this what are you talking about
and so explain yourself we were so proud
well there's there's right across the
the spot where where my kids not come
and play with their toys that's my house
my home no a parson Michael Corleone I
said where where they play a lot of
youth sports there is a Mexican
restaurant that has a sign in front of
all the foods that they are selling
within their establishment okay and it
looked like just one on top of the other
like a lineup batting order looks like a
boys like what's a food line so am I so
we decided to create the ultimate rock
Meyer food lineup right
sounds like a baseball team and I've we
have handed to you if you would not it's
amazing you wouldn't if you wouldn't
mind reading through it
Brock Meyer voice hey my pleasure rich
as in batting first playing shortstop
carne asada
batting second at second base unagi
unagi yeah I'm gonna guess that his
first name is Ichiro Suzuki we don't
know we don't know it just goes with
maybe the first name is Cavs just know
he's he if you if you throw the ball on
the outside corner to an Auggie he's
going the other way he'll slap it to
left field power-hitting first baseman
tortilla española if you've noticed
that's the the first three in the order
is the DoublePlay combination you're
right that is a combination sada to a
Naga to Espanola if you're scoring at
home and left batting cleanup Nutella
semifreddo behind the plate batting
fifth chestnut budino
is that like a pudding like a chestnut
pudding what was it was it like a
pudding last night putting it's a mousse
it's like a mousse from the Philippine
entry from the Philippines yes
centerfield
Lomo saltado although we're told us a
Peruvian dish right South American oh
yes sorry oh oh well all right no for
the Philippines we got some what number
eight okay batting seventh at third
Huckleberry Campos so we hear from the
southern part of the United States
that's a hot corner it's a hot corner
the compote in right field I think this
is a Filipino Jinju bibimbap bibimbap
yes and again from the United States of
America dick johnson is the pitcher you
could have done reality is funnier okay
what are you got you got Dickey found
you could have gone Johnny dick shot
remember him Johnny dick shot so his
dick pole wanted Paul Johnny dick shot
real guy yeah John walking first okay he
was commonly known as ugly Johnny diksha
[Laughter]
you also missed some guys from reality
yes cannonball Titcomb cannonball hit
them really oh yeah did you look this up
and right-field yeah sure did Pusha T Bo
you missed him that's a Bond villain
stubby clap you missed out on here's my
subtle favorite that's Orville overall
he was a pitcher we all know Antonio
Bastardo which I I giggled to myself
every time hear that one in Charlotte
man love he was a catcher Charlie Manuel
a man love absolutely another catcher
Tony Suk you see Kate Tony Suk
and of course at first finally Pete
Lacock 12 please I mean remember him of
course from the Kansas City Royals you
know you know his dad was right
I do not the host of Hollywood Squares
Peter Marshall was his dad yes his real
name was Lacock yes I can see Wow I did
not know there is some arcane Pete
Lacock knowledge for you sir
usually why'd you leave out piso mojado
that's usually a favor so Mahato yeah
ice honestly go down a wormhole every
single time I see a menu like that but
but you should do that your your son is
uh how old now he's about to be terribly
10 in June okay I explained my my kids
the other day asked me for the first
time does anybody call you dick mmm that
that's short for rich oh so they finally
caught on to that only caught on to that
one I so I say them not to my face women
giggling when they ask you yes and
proceeded to just decide just go for it
I told them about NASCAR driver Dan
Patrick favorite Dick Trickle
I believe that exactly existed and did
tell them about dick pol oh you did yes
and they didn't think it was for real
and I googled it and I showed it to do
that with your ten-year-old and see how
it works
mm-hmm it delights yes I miss with that
stuff oh my gosh
and they're 10 Jinju bibimbap designated
hitter easy with the D H but we decided
in deference to you this is a national
league menu lon thank you very much
pitcher bats beginner which we have
dueling no-hitters at citi field right
now even though it's one nothing yeah
one number we met home opener thing
really really give it a four and a half
no though and that's gotta run although
Matsuda guard that's you're down one
couple of walks and a sacrifice and
Strasburg hasn't given up ahead either
right through four and a half Wow how
about them apples all right
that would be uh ed by the way Strasburg
just gave up a hit really you are the
man you are the lush Chris Brockman is
the
mother of the Richards back who got the
hit I don't know you don't know caz
Suzuki it's no longer on the Mets Kazu
Nagi Wilson Ramos did congratulations
your new home oh this is off to Kathryn
star feet a lot Pete Pete he prefers
Pete Pete Alonzo good to see you sir
nice to thank you for coming on Congrats
on another season of of Brock Meyer
10:00 p.m. Eastern Time you added the
fantastic Richard Karn to the cast yes
we did fantastic
yes she's terrific I don't know if he'll
tell you that you have a terrific he
will tell you that they well this is
absolutely the mother is self-review of
him in the Music Man in regional theater
I forget what is that when he was
trotting the board's he actually used
the words that he was trotting the boys
my deaf right I was not a great Harold
Hill but I was a lot of fun to watch
reviewing himself that means means he
was slightly miscast it's not a small
light fully entertaining if he did say
so himself
yeah and blender he played poker he
refused to play with the bottom car I
will not play with the bottom car would
not if the if the deck was you know if
we were playing a game where you'd have
to use all the cards in the deck he
refused to play with the bottom card you
have to start start again that was
always a lot of fun unbelievable great
to see you Hank Hank Azaria on both
Twitter and Instagram check him out on
Brock Meyer on IFC the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience